To answer that question, we need to rearrange our data a
little bit. Right now, our data is in long format. We
have many rows. And, notice how that the variables that we
grouped over, male and female, have been repeated. They're repeated for each
year. So let's do something else besides this long data format.
What we're going to do is convert it to a wide format. This
new data frame will have one row for each age, and
then we'll put the median friend count inside of males and females.
Many times when computing with and exploring data,
it's helpful to move back and forth between these
different arrangements. To carry this out in R,
we're going to be using the reshape2 package. Now, if
the different between wide and long data is
still a little bit fuzzy to you, I recommend
pausing the video right now. You can read through
another example in the instructor notes before moving on.